[Music]
yeah so I mean really include question
is I mean how do you how do you expand
how do you in the very least change your
space of possibility and one way of
changing of course is to expand it and
especially if doing so requires you to
step into uncertainty because if
everything is really nice inside your
little village when during evolution
what a stupid idea to see what's on the
other side of the hill because now
you've just increased the possibility of
dying because dying is actually really
easy right
so in fact we even have a safety bias
that our assumptions of gears towards
safety because again it's easy to die so
what are other tricks are there ways or
their principles that enable people to
step into a certainty and the answer is
yes because it's such an important point
it's such an important space to be that
evolution also gave us a solution to
that so if you think what is the one
activity where uncertainty is not simply
tolerated it's actually celebrated it's
actually sought it's a way of being and
we have a name for that way of being
which we call science so science is not
defined by a methodology which is too
often thought to be what science is if
you think what defines a good scientist
or or good science it's this way of
being that celebrates uncertainty it's
open to possibility it's inherently
cooperative and it's what we call
intrinsically motivating right the
reason for doing a discovery the reward
for discovery the discovery itself
almost everything we do in the world we
do one thing in order to get a reward
that's different from the thing that we
did you work to get money but the
inherent reward for science for
discovery is the discovery itself now if
you think and what's more science have
an intention now if you see think about
those first three or four principles
celebrating uncertainty open a
possibility inherently motivated
inherently cooperative those are the
exact same definitions of play right
which means that science is a like play
science is
but it's play with intention and if you
add rules to play you have a game which
is nothing other than an experiment
right and what's true for science it
actually transcends science because
anything that is creative is effectively
play with intention so this concept of
there being a distinction between art
and science is complete arbitrary
because these are different
methodologies for applying the same
underlying principle way of being which
is play with intention and this isn't
actually and this isn't to say that
science is playful and fun and all that
which I find to be a slightly trivial
way of trying to get people into science
because to play well is hard right talk
to an Olympic athlete right to get two
gold medal is a really hard thing to do
to play chess incredibly well is really
hard so to do science to be creative
really well is hard but nonetheless it's
a way of putting your brain into a space
that where it's open and celebrates
uncertainly a possibility which is
inherent in actually good leadership
because what defines a good leader is
how you lead others into uncertainty
which means you have to create an
ecology and environment that enables
people to celebrate the possibility ask
questions search discover
[Music]